[Musique]
ibrahim extrêmement ému de revoir ces
images mais ouais c'est pas une buse
n'inquiétait pas higuain vraiment en eux
je suis pas venu seul
je prie aime j -ja tabou il vraiment de
ce que vous vivez ça fait ça fait
maintenant deux ans ouais qu'ibrahim
tous les soirs tous les jours il se
demande comment il va vivre le jour
prochain n'est plus aux enfants depuis
depuis deux ans et ça aussi on m'aime
plus souvent parce que comme moi company
a perdu un prototype tu donc à l'aise et
sociaux qui ont plaidé enfants avaient
pu les deux petits derniers les places
et donc du coup moi je travaille c'est
le samedi c'est le samedi dimanche j'ai
le temps à partir du moment je peux le
temps ce que quelqu'un dans le bâtiment
tu es fatigué à la fin de la semaine
s'il faut encore prendre le truc
le transall avons pas mal jusqu'à demain
c'est un bon loin de prendre le train
régional la base est allé se rendre au
chevet des enfants nation ouais mais bon
c'est vrai que les associés me donner de
nous avons envie de travailler vous êtes
couvreur d'autres coureurs
mais vu votre situation aujourd'hui vous
n'avez plus la force de travailler tous
les jours autant pouvoir vous avez du
travail que vous avez pu trouver les
cheveux je suis la bz
elle intègre une base d'intervention des
failles a pas de mission non plus quoi
avec nous confirmons que ça ne marche
pas la situation
qu'est-ce que vous aurez ex comment
comment on peut arranger les choses qu
est-ce qui qu'est ce qui ferait que vous
pourrez repartir quelques coups de pouce
on peut vous donner pour que vous
repartiez ampoules ou un premier il faut
que je vous fais mes premiers en effet
la seul certificat de paint voilà le bon
sens sans domiciliation vous ne pouvez
pas vous pouvez pas non en fait c'est un
peu mais ce seront des sollicitations ne
peut pas refaire ses papiers
si vous n'avez pas taillé ou pouvait pas
travailler
enfin comment ils vont louper c'est ça
donc là en fait c'est sans fin
aujourd'hui vous êtes dans une impasse
mois d'octobre alors je vous dis j'ai
appelé cet après midi mes équipes ont
appelé emmanuelle wargon la ministre du
logement
je lui dit qu'on allait l'appeler ce
soir et alors j'ai vu que beaucoup de
gens de moins interpellé hier sur les
réseaux sociaux notamment twitter
on me dira cyril est ce que tu peux
aider ibrahim alors bien entendu
j'aimerais aider tout le monde vous le
savez j'aimerais franchement voilà si
j'avais une baguette magique bien sûr
j'aimerais aider tout le monde
ibrahim ce soir je vais appeler la
ministre du logement
je veux voir ce qu'elle peut faire pour
vous si vous pouvez et c'est peut être
d'avoir un rendez vous avec elle qu'elle
puisse essayer de démêler cette affaire
pour vous et moi j'aurais aussi une
proposition à vous faire ensuite une
fois qu'on l'a eue alors j'appelle tout
de suite emmanuelle wargon c'est la
ministre du logement et on espère qu'on
va voir des bonnes nouvelles
alors oui bonsoir madame la ministre
mais c'est cyril hanouna
voilà vous êtes en direct avec nous je
suis que vous aussi vous avez regardé
ibrahimi r1 sur m6 bonjour oui moi aussi
j'ai regardé ce reportage et ça m'a
beaucoup ému et je voudrais dire qu en
réalité on va l'aider à démêler sa
situation
on va l'aider pour voir comment lui
trouver un poids et comment aussi de
redonner à créer au droit dont il a
besoin
la santé etc
moi je suis confronté à toutes ces
situations de détresse et on ouvre des
places en un on travaille avec les
grandes associations constaté la croix
rouge d'emmaüs
l'état finance nativement des presse à
l'hôtel des places dans des centres
d'hébergement suffisamment pour que ça
t'a cette détresse on sera pas
complètement démunis on peut pas être
attentif à sa situation
voilà je voudrais dire que justement moi
mon ministère on est super mobilité pas
coté comment ça va se passer pour
ibrahim
il va vous allez mettre des gens en
contact avec lui avec notre production
pour que nos jeunes ont pu céder ou
autres voir quelles solutions proposez
quand on sait que propose avec le dire
merci en tout cas emmanuelle wargon
ministre du logement d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir et on va s'occuper du breil
merci emmanuel merci beaucoup à lundi
merci merci au revoir
voilà alors donc ibrahim c'est plutôt
des bonnes nouvelles et moi au nom de la
production à mon nom sachez que vous
serez logés à l'hôtel à mes frais dès ce
soir
voilà donc ce soir où sera l'hôtel las
et voilà c'est pour nous jusqu'à voilà
pendant pendant un an
voilà voilà histoire de repartir
[Applaudissements]
merci merci brahim aussi